okay all right I don't know why I keep
doing all right you can be honest have
you recovered from me pranking you
earlier do you still feel it wasn't you
saw I was a little torn up by that right
but I think I'll recover I know it
wasn't at your level oh you know what
you've got the fans oh it's okay I
thought it was a fan I'm glad you know
her well your director was just telling
me that the Riverdale fans were
sometimes trying to sneak on set for
this when did that happen
sequence it for what for filming the
movie for I still believe he said
they're trying to get on set and see you
the Riverdale fence I don't know about
any of that they kept it for maybe maybe
they did I don't know well you just
posed with Egan possibly the coolest kid
I've ever met
oh my god he told me that he was
practicing his cage a model face for the
red carpet did he show it to you did you
do it he showed it to me we did it
together I think I can't wait to see
that photos can we see it from you I
don't know what it is really I'm not
really too sure what it what it is he's
only thinking about it I was thinking
about it
he was great was very personally
I also heard from Nicolas you just said
it now to legend he said was your
favorite word onset can you explain to
us what legend is I know this is a term
that maybe Americans don't know it's a
legend to describe a legend is to
describe someone who has created history
in some way I think I mean he said you
used it a lot he was like everything was
legend for yeah I mean but we're all
creating history right now you know he
also did say and I don't know if
Nicholas was throwing you under the bus
but he said you did take your shirt off
a couple times during was that just to
get a workout in ER Hey Mobile Alabama
in the summer
a taught it gets hot it gets really hot
now tell me who's supporting you here
today did I see mom and dad and is that
Charles yeah this is Charles Charles
decided to show up he's a legend did he
eat did he hit you in in a in a certain
place it's just a little thing two boys
every now and then we get a little
excited and then you know check somebody
he was thinking about doing it to me
just an it I know I can read your mind
I can read your mind hey what time you
gonna be home tonight what time will you
be in bed time okay cool I'll be home
I'll see you later we're living together
right now are you how's that going it's
really Shonda I love you okay I got to
go okay but real quick was that mom and
dad here to support you that was mom and
dad they're proud they're proud yeah I
mean I think you said this is the most
important project you feel like you've
ever done I'm so happy right now anyway
I mean it's very rare that you get to be
a part of a project where you come out
of it looking back and being like wow
every moment in that and that experience
I was so prison you know in every single
moment and I felt every single moment
and I feel like that's what we captured
we captured you know this beautiful
story between two people that was real
and I feel like the whole project was
anointed you know and and and everything
just worked out perfectly and I've never
been a part of something that's just
sunk like that you know it feels good
[Music]